ah oui je t'interdis montchamp elie
semoun et autres qualifiés dans la
personne publication vous saviez que
j'allais vous mettre un petit peu cette
émission on se connaît très bien
j'aimerais que clovis ou devine les
imitations le laisse deviner des vents
de près parce que manu voeux vient
provient pas de moi mais du chef du
service japonais du plus injuste le je
te donne les mecs à imiter mlle dans
l'oreille les filles vont donc alors
maintenant vous allez jouer chez moi
c'est celle des amis à perdre est à rien
de donner comme règle du jeu donne des
mcs a imité dans l'oreille cassée jaya
tu imites sûr et qui est qui qui doit te
dirai c'est que les élèves le château à
nikos aliagas dans le château des
bénévoles qui s'appelle la crise
il est arrivé là bas j'étais toi tu peux
denis fausse car à l'époque du château
non c'est à dire que mam à mon job
à l'époque si on pourrait appeler ça
comme ça un job c'était un tracé qui
fait affaire d'ailleurs sur comédie
était d'éviter effectivement dans la
star academy nikos fin des trains nikos
pour comédie et donc mon travail
consistait tous les soirs à dire âmes le
château les arabes le château le château
il a mené la loi s'il faut faire son
l'adage d'impôts et puis ensuite à la
fin quand il ya un mec qui se faisait
jeter du château le ton devenait plus
grave mais avec les mêmes moïse et les
élèves
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oui je t'interdis montchamp et je suis
auto qualifié dans la personne pour te
dit alain foka méritait mieux contre
elie semoun attention pas de réponse de
clovis il ya quelqu'un qui fait très
bien je vais revenir dans de petits
pantins fait mal et ça va être chaud
c'est jean son éloge alors quoi je suis
atterré de bonnes sensations
voilà ça c'est fait vachement c'était
mieux que toi et il le fait bien
vous connaissez votre mauvaise foi au
vestiaire lycée ou alors il y est ce que
vous êtes déjà allé sur état est ce que
vous allez sur l'année
[Rires]
ah oui non si tu la pareille mais il
faut que je dise son nom sinon ne sera
jamais je vais bien tuchan quoi voilà je
vais te montrer que tu vois je suis
vraiment je suis ton pote et je vais
faire pour toi ce délire bonjour un sou
très content sauf que ce que vous venez
aussi en direct dans une émission qui se
passe comment berne parce qu'on vous ait
des débats qu'ils font un bilan bien les
nomme pas mais regarde ses cris sont pas
là je sais qui c'est mais si vous
trouverez chez vous c'est impossible
c'est possible tu sais que ma mère qui
ces noms et pas du tout entier devrait
ainsi on peut voler mais non mais c'est
introuvable
et puis ça pis elle voulait que je
franchis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]